you want to lead us in we don't have
Jake today so we're kind of short on
music yes
well we all have instruments oh we do
and they're called our voice box all
right ready ready one two three
sit back home back home welcome back uh
we we have a really fun show today
something that is uh certainly very dear
to me a topic that I care a lot about
the idea of film school or just really
School for the Arts in general uh we are
joined with a plethora of beautiful
people today Griffin
thanks for having me Jonah hi and Nick
not Matt it's Nick let's get those reps
in guys
um I think so I kind of had an identity
you're starting to relate more to I
might be that we'll navigate it I'm like
am I mad yeah so it's a tough question
but uh you know we want to talk about
Film School like the relevancy of it the
importance of it question mark I know
for me you know I went to Chapman film
school for one year and dropped out I
don't know about you guys where did you
guys go and how long did you stay there
I went to Northern Illinois University
and I graduated with a bachelor's right
on uh so I went to Emerson uh and I also
graduated but I took a kind of a Hiatus
in the middle and I studied uh Film
Production there I'll say yeah I went to
Brooks Institute of Photography now
closed and got a BFA in film uh
cinematography and editing was kind of
the focus yeah but I got a ton of
questions about like hey did you go to
film school should I go to film school
yeah me too like that's probably one of
the
like most common questions I received
just from you know cold met cold call
messages or whatever you know people
reaching out and I'm kind of conflicted
on what to say to be honest I get like
where do you stand like are you Pro or
oh God I don't know I mean like
overall yes like hey if if you can
afford it and make it happen then I
think it's an overall good experience
but do you need film school to be
successful heck no yeah heck no
especially these days yeah like film
school has never been uh like less
needed I think now because everything's
so accessible it's a it's like a really
we're in an interesting kind of
Department here with visual effects I
know like I went to Chapman for one year
and I was very much of the mindset that
you know I I come I'm like zero
generation here my family moved here
from England when I was three years old
my brother dropped out of music school
and so I was like the last the last kid
in the college system and both my
parents were very very Pro getting the
degree and I was too I was of the
mindset that I'm gonna be summa [ __ ]
laude I want to be the guy at Film
School like this is the path that I'm
supposed to take in order to grow as an
artist and I spent one year at Chapman
and I remember feeling uh pretty let
down to be be totally honest with
not necessarily the infrastructure just
my access to the things that I was
craving because I was always self-taught
through high school with visual effects
and with editing and I went there with a
focus in editing and Film Production
and like one of the first things out the
gate that I wanted to do was take an
editing class and the way that they
prioritized the different students they
would say okay well you know freshmen
and seniors get priority and then the
Juniors and then the sophomores and I
was coming in as a sophomore okay which
side note I went to PCC and I followed
the exact curriculum you needed to
transfer to be a junior
and they just disregarded some of the
classes and they're like well this one
doesn't count this one doesn't count and
I'm like so wait now I need to take
Spanish again at full rate like there's
a reason I went to Community College to
get rid of some of the General Ed
classes that you don't want to pay full
whack for and they just disregarded them
so that was my first like moment whoa
that's that's not cool
um and you know I didn't end up getting
to take any editing classes they filled
up instantly and uh I got in I think I
got in one visual effects class or
something but everything else was like
essence of acting like these these these
studies that I guess if you don't know
what you want are good uh but if you
know exactly what you want out of film
school it's it's not ideal to have to
run the Gambit of every single
Department you know what I mean oh we
got a guest
[Music]
well we will soon I very much I very
much relate to your experience yeah um
yeah very much relate because I had the
same feeling when I like the idea of
film School moving like going in and
when I got there a lot of gen EDS a lot
of yeah the essence of acting or
directing actors on screen which are
like great classes I actually think that
they're too soon like I think that for
90 of kids who go like right into
college it's just you're not going to
absorb enough of it it's not worthwhile
at that age like if you're in your like
18 19 you're in a college environment
it's the dream to be in college
everyone's going out partying everyone's
meeting friends is this the time to like
deep dive into like the essence of like
what it means to direct someone and like
really envelop a character like some
people might be able to do it but like I
would say like 90 of people at 18 19
years old it's a waste of money not
because it's not a quality education but
because you're not a quality candidate
yet yeah and you the thing about
becoming an artist and living as an
artist
is maturing and realizing how to hone
your craft and it's just like is it
worth shelling out thousands and
thousands of dollars at that age to get
those things I don't think so yeah and
for those of you who don't know like who
haven't been to film school or haven't
been yet maybe uh the way that it works
I mean me transferring in as a sophomore
the idea was that you're sharing general
education classes with the phone classes
that you're taking and if you're doing
Film Production they want to give you a
run of at everything they want you to
get a taste of every single department
so you get a better sense of what it is
that you like or what you don't like and
that's great and that's super helpful
for some people I'm not saying that it's
not it's just for me I knew what I
wanted going in and there were so many
restrictions in place like I wanted to
do uh focus on editing and I wanted to
do a minor in visual effects and I had
to I literally had to run the Gambit for
months with a teacher sponsor filling
out forms navigating the appropriate
channels to meet the head of the film
school and ask her can I please do this
with you know in this at this private
Institute that I'm paying to be at can I
please stay what's the game of that I
had five minutes with her and she said
they're too similar
and that was it and I looked at the the
professor who who supported me and he's
like all right we have to go back to the
beginning of the process again and I was
like this is crazy like they're they're
similar because I I want to use them
both that's that's why I wanted two
similar things because I want to make a
career out of these two things and uh I
was shut down pretty hard and I remember
just being like I'm paying top whack to
be here and I don't feel like I have the
flexibility too the point where I
actually had a laundry list of tutorials
that I didn't have time to do until the
summer
and I remember telling myself it's okay
like I was in audio engineering class or
something and I was like it's okay just
focus on this for now and you can learn
in the summer and then I caught myself
and I was like that is so backwards yeah
I have to wait till the summer to learn
for free while paying tens of thousands
of dollars to be in an environment that
doesn't fit me yeah um and I feel like
there should be more flexibility for
fitting the students you know what I
mean I think it comes down like why do
you want to go to film school why do you
want a higher education and you know I
think Jonah why did you want to go to
film school for instance
I wanted to go to film school because
similar to Jordan my dad he's a teacher
so there was never a question of whether
or not I was going to college like it
was just that I had parental expectation
it was a huge print so I would say that
was like number one cool honestly I can
relate yeah yeah I think most people can
probably relate to that and you're like
thinking about should I go to film
school or not and then number two is it
was something that I was one of the only
things I was truly passionate about at
that time and I was very excited at the
prospect of like going to a place of
Higher Learning and being able to be
given like the facility to experiment
that was a really critical critical to
me and I had visited the Emerson campus
and I saw like
the TV studio and the rental area and I
was my eyes got all big and I was like
oh this is a place where I can like
really
put kind of the rubber to the road and
be able to like work on this and that's
obviously an intentional thing that they
do when you tour and then they say hey
by the way that's like for the seniors
yeah by the way it's gonna be three
years
and then the the red tape and what about
you Griffin what was kind of like your
process getting into it so I I didn't go
to film School unlike you guys I went to
art school I got a degree in
illustration
um still very relevant I feel like it's
the same kind of thing though yeah
I I went because like from the time I
was like very little I was like I want
to be an artist when I grow up everyone
says you get out of high school you go
to college like this is how I be an
artist
and I think that in previous times like
the reason why you would go to art
school is you have access to working
Professionals in the field who will show
you how to do what they do and like
you're saying you have facilities and
materials and for a very long time it
was a a very affordable thing
and I don't regret doing it I met some
of my best friends in life I was in like
a community of like-minded artists
and I had some good professors because
my my department was very good but
even though the department was good
looking back
a lot of the the learning I did was
still on my own in my bedroom and like
it's not like
um it's not like every day they were
like okay this is how you put together
like a basic
palette for painting different skin
tones it was like here's your assignment
and go do it then you go home and you're
in your drafting table and you're like
are figuring it out and
the simple fact is like I'm not going to
say that they're equivalent or that one
can replace the other but
if you want to learn from a professional
illustrator like how do you do
convincing and Lively human skin tones
you go on youtube.com for free because
that's what we were doing we were like
looking stuff up on YouTube at home
after class to do the assignments and
like
you know and the crazy thing we were
still paying for materials like yeah
um you know we were paying myth like lab
and materials fees to the college and
then had to bring our own materials
anyway because but
you know the the cost and and it's very
different for film it's very different
for things where you need like a
computer that can handle it and software
licenses and gear but if you're talking
about art specifically
you don't necessarily need a Wacom or
adobe you can go to to Blick or
Michael's and
that hundred dollars worth of art
supplies and some time on YouTube
is a lot cheaper than you know I went to
a state school and it was still pretty
expensive if if I'd gone to a private
art school which I'm sure is very
similar to film School
American private art schools are some of
the most expensive schools in America
sometimes up there and above like ivy
league it's like that's
this is yeah it doesn't make any sense
why no yeah I dude I think yeah a lot of
the things that you build along the way
at film school and I assume with your
experience with your degree as well is
like
build confidence and build relationships
right and at a young age I think that's
really important and sometimes you can't
do that for yourself but what you're
talking about makes me feel like what
you want to be doing is that
self-teaching but also the most
important thing in this industry all
creative Industries is building
confidence in yourself and then putting
yourself out there and that's what a lot
of these college programs kind of like
are trying to do for you which is like
here's an advisor here's like a peer
group here's your internships that are
available to you and then they like try
and kind of push you through that door
and for me I just really hated the like
how confined that was and I just found
my own that we're like cooler I found
them on like Instagram and then I found
them through friends and suddenly I was
working with people that I really liked
instead of working at like the local TV
station and then I was like okay then
why am I paying thousands of dollars for
like your resources when like I actually
don't really I'm not like super into the
resources that you're able to give me
yeah
um and that was that was when it started
really like falling apart for me where I
was like okay so I don't super love the
classes I feel like I can't really give
this all my attention and what I feel
like I'm receiving from you in terms of
like actual
industry help is like a direction that I
don't really want to be going in and so
I don't know I was that kind of where it
fell apart for you for for me it was it
was certainly the lack of control over
my schedule I wasn't learning the things
that I wanted to learn but I was paying
top top dollar to learn things that I
didn't yeah
um I I'd much rather have the free time
to look online and do those things
um but what one thing that I will say
about film school that was tremendously
beneficial and we've all kind of touched
on it already which is interesting is
the relationship aspect because what
you're doing is you're entering a world
of like-minded people and that's
incredibly valuable and I'm still
friends with a lot of people that I met
at Chapman and that made it worthwhile
for being there for the year
um but I'm really glad that I left when
I did because you know I didn't I wasn't
interested in being a DP I didn't need
to get my hands on on all that gear and
and all the things that they have access
to on the directing side I started
directing right out of college as soon
as I left I started commercial directing
right out the gate just funding my own
projects selling them to clients and
making enough to make bigger and bigger
projects and I made my career that way
and you know even looking at the visual
effects side of things I learned by
doing and I feel like learning by doing
is is the move in in every aspect if you
ask most people where they feel like
they've grown the most it's on set it's
doing those late night you know freaking
deep Dives because you are so passionate
about this subject you're you're just
pulling resource from wherever you can
and there's so much free resource now
more than there's ever been and there's
also more high quality teachers for
cheaper than they've ever been all
online I mean we're talking of in visual
effects terms I want to learn Houdini I
can find a course by Stephen nipping
who's a technical director at ilm
teaching me how to do an explosion that
he's actively doing in the Star Wars
films and I can email him and he'll
respond to me he's done it for like 75
bucks are you kidding the best mines in
the industry a minute of Dodge College
time probably yeah legit and that's one
of the things right one breath is the is
the cost like like you're saying the
cost is so out of whack it doesn't make
any sense and I I drove I lived off
campus for my experience and I had to
drive 30 miles to get there and 30 miles
back and so it was a trek to get there
every single time in one day that really
hit me in the gut was I drove 30 miles
out there for an acting class I didn't
want to take an acting class I wasn't
interested
um and but I you know I was I was gonna
do well in this college it was my
mindset and I got there and I pulled up
and there was a notice on the door from
the professor and she's like I'm not
feeling well like no class today 30
minute warning it took me 45 to drive
there so I wouldn't have seen it and I I
look at the notice and the other kids
who were in the class behind me are like
yeah yeah no no class and I was like
guys we still have to pay for it we have
to pay for that for for someone who's
not going to show up
like online courses I can save them for
when I need them I can watch them again
I do it all the time I take notes on
them I watch them I revisit them I email
the teachers from the courses I never
felt like I had that at Chapman and
there there is benefit if you're going
for the for those reasons that Chapman
provides you know the gear and and the
friendships and whatnot but I feel like
a year in house for me was enough to to
make the friends to meet the people and
then dip and do my own thing and stay in
touch and that's it's kind of like a
nice Middle Ground of getting the
advantage of a film school but not
committing full force to to just what
could likely be just poverty for like a
multi-year stretch of time of just
feeding this Beast well something
something I want to I want to add into
because
um
like
an interesting positive for college is
like sure there was a lot of
self-learning that I did but I I don't
want to make it sound like I know for
certain that I would have been just as
well off being self-taught because
I think like what I went for very much
was mentorship and on hands learning and
I I don't want to say that I never got
that because I don't think that's fair
and having accountability and deadlines
and the teachers you know getting us to
think in certain ways and giving us
assignments and you know if there was
like an alternate reality Griffin who
just was like a bedroom self-taught
artist stacked up against today I don't
know if we'd be equivalent it's fair
yeah and the the unfortunate truth
though is like
um it's the same thing kind of like
we're all saying though is like
when you're you're paying like hundreds
of thousands of dollars for that
Hands-On mentorship and that
accountability and those assignments
like
how much how worth it is that extra
investment yeah if you were to be able
to do it again Nick like where would you
stand in your like choice
it's hard to say man I kind of agree
with Griffin it's a you can't like be
like yeah I mean Griff and I you know
having finished and kind of gone through
the whole thing mine was a three-year
program but I'm not sure how long yours
was it's like yeah I can't for sure say
this is where I'd be but you know
I'd been making movies all through high
school all through Junior College at JC
classes to get credits Done Cheap you
know
um and was like yeah I'll just take a
year
during that time I made YouTube shorts
and that's how I met Brett that's how I
eventually met Sam and Nico you know
um Clint you know we were all making
short films and connected through
YouTube that's how we all met and I mean
those friendships are still strong that
wasn't film school yeah
and the funny part is you know when I
finally did move down here found a film
school that finally like I really liked
and seemed like it would have good
resources
you know after all that
here I am you know in a job now with all
you guys that is
all that whole connection was made
completely independent of the film
School experience like there were like
these two parallel things going on
there's like the YouTube Nick and the
film School in there like Film School
Nick you know could have taken his
thesis project and gone and you know
pitched it to Universal and become a
director not that that actually happens
anymore but yeah unless nepotism is
involved and this is that's totally
serious um
nepotism let's talk about it because
Jesus Christ dude like I was sorry sorry
Lord I was touring colleges and you know
obviously we went down to La it was like
a big trip
and I was like yeah we're gonna twirl
these big film schools that I've heard
all about
Loyola Marymount USC films Dodge College
Chapman yep those are the big three uh
what was the other one you sealed I said
that probably UCLA yeah yeah they're
great yeah and it's like wow there's
directors that come here like for like
one Symposium by the way
um
and
you know it sounds really great
and you get stars in your eyes when
you're walking through these campuses
and they're pointing out like oh yeah
this is where this was filmed this is
where this was filmed the steps at Dodge
College I remember you recognize that
you're like wow yeah right and then they
show you the film school and you see you
know the sound stages and the big
screening theater and the gear room and
you're like great
and then they're like yeah so you know
the process is you'll take two years of
GE classes and you know if your grades
are good enough you'll be admitted to
some film classes you know and get your
hands on a camera maybe yeah and if
you're lucky you'll get chosen by
Lottery to be the director of a project
you know which don't you have to fund
those yeah yeah
that's crazy yeah oh yeah let's rent
some [ __ ] 35 packages on Mom and
Dad's credit cards so and when you're 19
18 you don't you don't understand money
but thinking that's the only way I can
direct a movie yeah that's what they
funnel you into from that very first
tour of the film school and if you're
touring film schools this is maybe we
can give you some instruction on what to
look for here because just be aware that
the whole thing is a money-making
Venture it's not about you learning yeah
it's about making money and if you are
successful they get to put that on their
poster that's very true yeah so
it's all for profit yeah completely and
you are you're learning film is probably
not that higher in the list because
there's a million other kids that have
heard about USC or Chapman College film
program and all want to sign up yeah to
be the next Steven Spielberg but guess
what
guess what Steven Spielberg did he made
[ __ ] movies yeah he made them and
didn't wait three years taking GES
not that geez are bad I think obviously
the whole reason if you're thinking
about going to film school and getting a
higher education you probably want that
well-rounded education right
no no that wasn't you screw that dude
yeah I spent like five digit money to
learn how to be a professional artist
and you have me sitting in geology class
heartbreaking like yeah no we did that
all through High School it I I can
confidently say that general education
classes except for
basic household accounting
that was the one general education class
I took that was not a Monumental waste
of money yeah I don't know man I I kind
of disagree I think they're you know you
got to find the right school for you
that's what it comes down to
I so yeah
we toured you know all the big ones and
then I heard about this little school
called Brooks Institute of Photography
and they're like oh yeah they're up in
Santa Barbara
go up there tour it and we drive out to
the middle it seems like the middle of
freaking nowhere it's on the 33 freeway
I often Tura you're going out to this
town called Ojai and it's like where the
hell am I and we pull off and like we
drive up and there's huge sound stages
and it's like a back lot and it's like
what yeah
and then you know they have the school
was on an old like Universal lot like so
they had sound you know stages huge and
they'd broken it up into like eight
different stages you could build sets
they had permanent sets built they had
RED cameras they had you know dslrs were
just coming into the fold so they were
getting those which was really cool it's
like ooh five D's sweet yeah
um
so like they had the resources and I was
like this is where I need to be plus you
get to get a camera in your hand they
they were willing to look at past work
and write off credits so you didn't have
to start in film 101 like here's a wide
shot here's a you know there's no wonder
this place went out of business they
were way too good yeah because it wasn't
for profit it was deeply we came to find
out oh I happened to join the last like
three years of the good years right
and after that things got really bad and
you know they started getting like the
school got sold to a education like
[ __ ] conglomerate like basically a
corporation that buys up for-profit
schools and tries to squeeze them for
everything yeah it's this Chinese
company they bought Brooks Institute and
within three years the whole school had
basically wow they basically made it
into a write-off so my goodness that's a
sad story
um and also you know sad for the fact
that Brooks doesn't exist so it's like
what what's the degree for yeah
there was some Silver Linings I got to
have a camera in my hand I got to build
sets I got to work on real sets
um with like a real crew and like that
was from day one
but I also got some really cool GE
classes I mean art history classes like
uh there was like a random architecture
class which was actually surprisingly
really eye-opening like there are all
these little things I mean obviously
math class was not my my choice I didn't
want to really spend too much energy in
that
but I do feel like
higher education comes with that like
and if you want to go to a trade school
that's something you should seriously
consider it'll save you a lot of
freaking money if you don't want to take
ge's look for a trade school like look
for somewhere that is like a quicker
program but gets you more Hands-On you
don't have to spend time in those
classes yeah like just know what you're
signing up for is all I would like plead
to you yeah you know think about all the
debt you're gonna go in and ask yourself
am I going to spend more time with the
camera in my hand here
or on YouTube make it in shorts yeah
yeah I would say oh along with that if
there's one thing that I could say
and I would I think I would do
everything I've done the same way I I
like to think that I would but if
there's one thing that I can impart on
someone who's like about to make that
choice along with what you're saying
I dare you that if you're about to make
the leap to like joining film school or
art school take a year
and PA
as much as you can into the people who
immediately hear me say that and say oh
there's no opportunities in my town or
there's no it's hard to like
everyone wants a cheap PA
and guess what it's hard and the rest of
your life it's going to be hard finding
like work and films so like if that's if
that's the threshold of you quitting
yeah quit now yeah because like you're
gonna have to put yourself out there and
if it doesn't go well and you can't
handle that not going well and you can't
handle being kind of literally the
lowest person on set for six weeks I
also think that you it might not be
ready for you to join this career and
that is way better to know before you
spend thousands of dollars right so and
and I could say you know I don't know
your industry as well but maybe
Apprentice someone you know or or work
at
[ __ ] it like a like a Blick and just
like get to know what you're gonna be
using for the rest of your life and
really like take that pause before you
decide to do that and in that time
you'll be so much better off and way
more prepared and understanding of how
the industry works at which point you
could be like oh I actually really only
like visual effects let's do a trade
school yeah oh you know what I realized
is like everyone on film on this film
set and every film set I've done for a
year is telling me that it's a waste of
money I really really love history I'm
gonna study that and then make the
coolest historical films ever because
I'm really passionate about history like
that to me is like a really
sophisticated way to go about it because
everyone not everyone can go to film
school but everyone has an iPhone
everyone
can do it to a degree what makes you
special hone that as a young person so
if you're going to spend a lot of money
maybe spend it in another discipline
because this one is
pretty accessible yeah well that's the
thing too is it's the idea of structure
right like this is one thing that I
accidentally found out that I was pretty
good at is structuring my own like
learning and and putting together the
different things that I need to learn in
order to to get to a certain point and
it's also my hobby filmmaking or or
specifically visual effects is my hobby
so when I leave here I go and I do
visual effects like I go right into it
and I I enjoy that and so that
discipline that is something that I've
kind of developed over time uh lends
itself very nicely to growing and
learning in a Solo environment because
the reality is the minute that you're
out of the school system like if you're
in high school right now you're told
where to go when to be there and that is
really beneficial for for some people
because you know when no one's telling
you what to do it's so so easy to just
go and play video games I'm gonna watch
I'm gonna watch movies I'm gonna I'm
gonna binge you know House of the dragon
and go to sleep or it's very very easy
to turn your mind off and so if you feel
like you are not the most disciplined or
you haven't develop that in yourself
that's something that you can work on in
the background but the the structure of
film school might still be very
beneficial to you but yeah if you if you
are a very disciplined person or you are
you're open to becoming disciplined then
there is a vast Avenue of learning
available to you and I believe that
everyone can can learn to be disciplined
it's just getting the Reps in and
getting used to this new way of life
because you know if if you can be
disciplined in school you can be
disciplined on your own it's just a
matter of you telling yourself what to
do or finding courses that are
structured already like I talk about
this all the time you know there's
there's websites like Rebel way for
Houdini that give you an eight-week or
ten week Arc of what to do over this
week you got to do this this week you
gotta do this and you know parse out
your time do what you need to do meet
the goal by the end of the week and do
the same thing and the same thing and
it's it's the same idea of just turn
your homework in but it's a lot more
curated you have access to the classes
for the rest of your life
um and again it's the idea of you don't
really know who you're going to get as a
professor and there's some excellent
professors of homeschool I'm certainly
not saying that but you know exactly the
professor that you are choosing and that
is another thing about film school that
I find very interesting the Rate My
Professor thing I don't know if that's
still a thing oh yeah but I scramble the
right by Professor I want the best one I
want the one that maybe people find hard
or challenging or interesting you know
because I don't want the hot tamale
teacher I'm not interested like the idea
that it's you can't even necessarily
pick the instructor and you may get
landed with the one that nobody wants at
the same rate as the great one that
everybody's clamoring for is it's not
ideal and it's it's hard to make that
available for everybody but I think a
lot of people want that structure and
need it though yeah it's beneficial
certainly yeah it was like you know a
year of junior college is kind of in my
hometown still making movies and stuff
but you know I felt a lack of structure
I was like I want to go somewhere where
it's just like I know when I'm going to
show up I'm going to learn about film
learn about art you know be in a new
place too and like have kind of have a
goal and you know having that was I
think beneficial for me at that age like
when the Alternatives were you know
float around and you know smoke weed or
you know party friends or you know just
make good YouTube videos so it was
very like that was just for me it was
nice yeah I do want to kind of go back
to what you were saying though Joan
about you know getting on set and peeing
and like starting from the bottom
I hate to break it to you but you're
probably gonna be doing that anyway
after you finish it yeah yeah no it's
very true it's very true like I think
one thing that you do here a lot from
you know people who don't go to film
school is about how snooty people who
went can be when they got on set because
they're expecting to you know come in at
an entry-level job yeah whereas
no one really cares at all that you went
to film school no one really great so
you know how to open a c-stand good do
it that's what you'll be doing go to the
grip truck and
you're gonna start from the bottom
almost like either way in my experience
at least got out of film school you know
I was doing freelance cinematography but
like yeah when times got slow it was
like [ __ ] I'll take some PA work like
let's go like
a couple hundred bucks a day hey it's
just they're open in C stands is um is
there an equivalent Griffin like that
entry level like first step that you
recommend to someone if maybe before or
after that is like maybe not as talked
about yeah so I think I think this might
be an example of where like film and art
differ because
um you know if your dream in life is to
work on like major Motion Pictures there
there probably isn't like a way to
necessarily do that as like a hobby like
I don't know how feasible it is to make
Interstellar on nights and weekends but
uh hopefully there's something that
applies to to everyone in any creative
field for this is
I would encourage you before going to
Art School to think really carefully
about whether or not this is something
that you want to be your career or just
to be like the thing you do because in
my life I've noticed there's really no
way to know until you've done it for a
job but
I I've seen enough people go to art
school because you know every guidance
counselor you know everyone in their
family was like you got to go to college
what's the thing you're good at and
they're like the thing I'm good at is
I'm I like drawing and then they go to
art school and they're like man I don't
like it like this because the truth is
much as an art professional
unless you are super super fortunate
you are going to spend a lot of time not
drawing what you want to draw you're
going to be drawing other people's ideas
the way other people want them a lot of
the time it's not going to be stuff you
like doing
um
and you know you might get to a point
where people really you know they pick
you because they value
what you know the thing that you love
doing is what's valuable to their
project and you end up on a project
where you're drawing exactly what you
want to
um or you know you kind of grind your
way into that like RISD to New York
editorial illustrator thing where you
just get paid by magazine art directors
to draw random stuff in your style but
if it is okay
if you don't want to draw other people's
drawings the way they want them to and
it is okay if you want to have a a gig
doing something and energy to do what
you love there is nothing wrong with
that and in fact that might be better
than ruining the thing that you love by
doing it for money I would I would be so
much happier for anyone listening to
this
if you
maintained Your Love of drawing or
painting or whatever creative thing and
didn't do it for a job in rather than
because I have a dude I've had I've had
years where like I hated being creative
because I was you know doing some work
where I just sapped all my Creative
Energy and then I was like well
I'm not like making anything I'm proud
of
so why am I not just like there's a time
period where I was looking into becoming
an apprentice cheese maker okay that's
really cool because I was like dude this
whole this whole art career thing is not
panning out like I've always loved
cheese like could I make cheese and then
okay that wasn't I mean
it's a tough industry to break into
it but um
I believe cheese mongers
I'll just be over here soaking in that
humor uh what you said actually really
reminds me of my sister who like I
really look up to and she did exactly
that and I can tell you firsthand so
she's an Air Force nurse and she is like
a complete badass and studied and did
ROTC along with a Nursing degree and was
just completely focused on that career
and while she was doing that she just so
happens to be I would say confidently
the best artist I know like when it
comes to like drawing uh painting
acrylic uh she does like
um and I'm gonna butcher it but when you
like cut the negative out of something
and then like press the
mongering yeah
and she'll spend you know she has a
career where she's able to work a shift
for two weeks at a time and then she has
a week sometimes she'll just spend that
whole time drawing she she like she was
like I'm just gonna figure out how to
like make a skateboard so she just spent
like a week and she like built one and
like yeah made like an ocean out of like
um
what's that style where they do it's
almost like shiny and that you like drip
it epoxy yeah so she made an epoxy
skateboard and then she just goes to
work and like what you're saying isn't
just advice like I see someone in my
life who does it and like I'm envious at
times because I'm like dude sometimes I
do kind of feel like man I wish I was
just like my mom's doing a trip right
now where she's biking all the way from
uh Banff down to Mexico and she's
filming the whole thing and she's like
hey
I really love for you to edit this for
me right and the jaded part of me says
Mom I don't have time for this I'm a
professional who's editing all day and
what my heart tells me is I actually
really wish that I could do that for my
mom yeah and I wish that my art
in the intersection of my art in my
personal life was like easier to handle
and because like it is love and I love
doing it it's just when you do it all
the time it gets really hard to do that
hey can you do this for me and my mom's
like I'll pay you and I'm like that's
worse yeah it's so worse that's so much
so much worse I don't want you to pay
like would you pay my sister to you know
make you a a little print like that's
absurd like I love you and so it's
something that I think we all deal with
and so if you
and and it's not to say that I don't
struggle with it but it's like if you
feel like that's already a problem in
your life when you're like just getting
into it yeah I think it's worth like
really yeah you know thinking about you
know and there's you could be a cheese
maker especially with how expensive the
thing is and like I I still have guilt
about the debt I put my parents in
because they're the best parents ever
and they're like yeah we want to help
you pay for this yeah I think we like
split it or whatever
but like
it's just it weighs on astronomical and
especially in the Arts dude yeah like in
Griffin you you can probably attest to
this even more because it feels like I
feel like there's less of a mold maybe
for Fine Arts like you do than there is
for film right because like film school
it's like okay yeah you have set jobs
you can go to but like what's the mass
job industry for an artist out of film
school like what is the goal there
there's definitely there's definitely a
mold in cheese though there is I mean
there you go you know I'm on fire go on
the nice thing with commercial like with
uh film schools like at least it's a
commercial art because when you go to
Art School it's um like I I have a
career in large part because I went into
a commercial art like illustration
graphic design there are day jobs for
that uh I know a lot of people who
follow their dreams they went for what
they were passionate about nothing wrong
with doing that by the way this is not
me saying anything negative about that I
think that's the right move
but
if if you get a BFA in oil painting or
like a BFA and graphite pencil drawing
or something like that
your options are kind of
get a masters and teach that or
hope that you know
somehow without nepotism you are able to
get a decent living out of the gallery
world because I think the only reason I
have a steady job is because
I studied illustration and was able to
kind of like talk my way into my first
entry-level graphic design job and
like without that you know I would
probably not have a career yeah my dad
did something kind of similar like to
what you're saying like he studied
graphic design like literally back in
the day it was like you know lining out
letters on a block like on a freaking
easel and like you know trying to make
it all work and you'd send the freaking
collage into the magazine they'd
hopefully like make it all work you know
it was like janky like yeah
pre-photoshop that got him by as he was
like drawing characters and cool
creatures and [ __ ] like he'd always been
doing that that was like his side hustle
and like he had to you know pay the
bills while he got his portfolio ready
and finally you know got a job at ilm
but like that was
that was the commercial field that he
studied for and that was I think a smart
move because it's like I can apply my
art to something that can actually make
me money and you know it paid off there
so like there's this idea though that
like you know the schools try to sell
you on
the success stories of you know like
what do we look up to we look up to like
fine artists you know the big ones that
we've all heard of we look up to
directors you know like the freaking old
school 70s director you know Lucas
Spielberg all those guys who were all in
the Coots with each other that's who we
look up to
like as a student aspiring to go yeah of
course and you know it dodged they were
like yeah we had this one uh director
she you know she got out of school and
her thesis got her like a music video
gig and she's like doing music videos
now it's like cool but that's like one
person yeah and like for me in my
experience at Brooks it's like
there are all sorts of people studying
all sorts of things but the consistently
most successful ones like after school
are the grips
this is not talking crap about grips
they're like some of the most
hard-working people on a dang film set
and they're jacked they're just so
strong also but like they had it right
because they freaking were like
there's a void like there's always
needed it's a very specialized like dude
being a grip is like you gotta know
everything about how to shape light and
you know whatever
and they're freaking getting paid now
they get paid whereas the directors are
like I don't know what I'm doing yeah
and like so yeah obviously there's some
directors and cinematographers who've
done really well yeah but like
they're they had it right I think it's
like yeah and you can do that with like
a certificate you can do that with a
trade school it's like if you really
want to be on a set think about how can
I make money and like not have to live a
hard life because I want to be this
director like you can do that stuff on
the side man and to and to jump off that
too in the visual effects World
specifically I found I had like a
roughly like a nine year freelance
career before working here and nine
years and yeah nine years crazy and I
was literally never without work because
there was a huge void of VFX artists who
are responsible who are responsive and
who can who can get the job done and I
found that you know it in this industry
it's a very relational industry and it's
always like it's all about who you know
which doesn't really help anybody it's
like okay so you know someone I don't
know that's not fair but the reality is
it's an incredibly small community and
you notice that producers love to share
names to other producers and they'll ask
you do you have anyone you can recommend
and so one of the biggest things that I
would recommend any VFX artists who are
entering the industry is obviously be
able to do the work so so do your
studies and make sure that you're
capable in The Craft
but be enjoyable to be with be enjoyable
to be around the first supervision gig
that I ever got was off a Facebook post
and I post and a friend of mine posted
my reel and it was for a big artist but
nobody knew what she wasn't like
forthcoming what was the name of the
artist it was yeah big artist
s [ __ ] reels and there were a plethora
of reels there and my friends submitted
mine which I bless him that was such a
sweet thing to do because I looked at
everybody else's real and good Lord they
were better than me they were just
really talented industry like industry
professional VFX artists but my real
I've made sure to include me dancing in
it because I thought it would be funny
that was the only thinking that I had in
my head for your quarters
and I was like and I was like dude I'm
gonna I'm gonna put me dancing in it
because it shows a little bit of me and
maybe people will want to be around that
kind of manic energy I don't know and I
I looked at other people's reels and
much better than me so I went to bed
just going oh that was very sweet
nothing will come of it and I I got a
phone call saying hey can you be on set
on Saturday wow uh and it was a music
video for Miley Cyrus and I was VFX
supervisor with no previous experience
oh my God and I got on set and I tried
my best to act like I knew what I was
doing I did yeah yeah no but she asked
me on the phone she's like do you know
how to do this this and this and I was
like yes yes and yes but it was no no no
yeah but that night I spent all night
studying those things so that when I got
to set I would be prepared and I was
when I said I felt felt very comfortable
and everything went well thankfully but
at the end I spoke to her one-on-one and
I was like I just gotta know like why
did you pick me thinking she was gonna
say like oh well in this shot you showed
Bubba no she's like you look like you'd
be fun to work with yeah are you kidding
yeah like it's that's yeah if I can if I
can touch on that that's I think that
applies to pretty much any job field
because the last job I got before
Corridor I was
um I think three weeks away from running
out of unemployment my my plan was to
basically
at in the next week go apply at
Starbucks and then apply at the
warehouse where my cousin was a trucker
for
and just like hope that I got something
in my field before the end of the year
um
and this place picked me
and I asked them right before I quit to
move to California to work here
um I was like because I was helping them
interview
my replacement and I was like so why'd
you guys pick me and they're like oh
yeah it was between you and someone else
who had like basically the same level
level of portfolio but like you had like
a joke we really liked at the top of
your website and like you just seemed
like a cool guy who I wouldn't mind
sitting next to you 40 hours a week and
it's not fair
but that's how it works a lot of the
time and it's interesting you bring up
that story about
saying yes yes and yes but really it's
no no and no because I've done that at a
lot of jobs too and when it's when you
hear something and someone's like can
you do this and
if you hear it and you're like no but
I'm confident yeah it's an important
distinction yes and what's really
interesting about that is that
statistically
um men are more likely to do that than
women and men are more likely to look at
a job listing that they are maybe not
qualified for and have that reaction
then women statistically at least in
America
and so I would just like to share that
for anyone listening
it is not only okay but a good idea yes
to kind of fudge that a little bit and
like if there's something that you don't
have experience doing or maybe you don't
know how to do but you're like I can
absolutely learn how to do that take
that risk because there's a good chance
it could get you that job that you might
have not applied for yeah yeah to jump
on that pile like the first opportunity
that I created for myself was I had a
family friend who had told me that his
his uncle
did commercials and uh Boston and I was
living up in New Hampshire or I was
visiting New Hampshire at the time so I
just I dm'd him and I was like hey I'm
it's the summer I'm between semesters
and uh like I just said advice to other
people I took my own advice and I was
like can I just work for you like if you
need a hand and he was like yeah you
want to like swing by we should you know
we could meet
and
I went to their studio in Austin
Massachusetts and they had just kind of
moved into the building
and we hung out a little bit and I was
hoping I made a good impression and then
genuinely the editor was working on a
Rolling Stones ad at the time and I was
so enamored by the process of the work
that we had kind of wrapped up and I got
the sense that they kind of wanted me to
leave
respectfully yeah and I spoke to the
editor I just kind of like to the side
and I was like hey I don't mean to be
intrusive but would it be a problem if I
just pulled up a stool I won't talk to
you I just really want to watch you work
like I just it it is so exciting to me
to see you like make this thing
and he was like oh sure man yeah and I
sat there for like six hours without
moving and I and that was all that we
had ever scheduled to do like that was
the whole meeting and then I just like
that the end of the day happened because
we had talked in the morning and I left
and the next day I got a phone call in
the morning and the guy who I dm'd was
like what are you up to today man
and I was like oh and I I think I made
something up because I didn't want to
see William and he was like um yeah Jack
needs a hand uh you should just come in
like let's just and I worked for them
every day that summer
and then the next summer I was their
assistant editor officially the summer
after that I became an editor there I
started working part-time through
college by the time I left there I was
one of the two editors at the company
and I had built a portfolio for myself
that I applied to Corridor with that's
all to say
just be a person who like genuinely
loves what they do and like wants to
learn more because that [ __ ] is
contagious and um you know you might not
run into an opportunity like that like
the first time you try I think I was
really lucky and I kind of like
lightning struck in a way but
it's what you're saying man it's just
you know if you're authentically
intrigued if you're like searching for
answers yeah answers will find you and
uh and yeah it's it's the idea also of
of lightening the room that you're in
like be a light for any room that you
enter and don't darken the mood and
don't don't bring negativity in and it's
it's something that you know throughout
my freelance career I've certainly had
my ups and downs you know you don't feel
too good and you bring a mood to set and
stuff like that and and I'll just
encourage anyone out there to maintain
positivity because that is a very
attractive quality in anyone that you
want to work with you want to be around
someone who makes you feel like oh just
a little bit lighter a little bit more
fun and a little bit more enjoyable
because the reality is this industry is
not that serious like we're making we're
making goofy things all over the world
movies you know with with Orcs And
stupid things exploding and aliens
coming and wobbling around like aliens
it's all nonsense anyway and so you know
keeping keeping that light alive inside
of you that that that Whimsical kind of
childish fun side uh will will make you
infinitely more attractive to
to people outside of college but you
know obviously to to bring it back to
the idea of being in University you know
it's yeah anyone out there who's
currently in and unsure it's like I can
tell you from my experience that no one
has ever asked for my degree no one has
ever really asked where I'm busy man
it's never it's it's never come up this
this whole podcast is like called should
I go to film school yeah I think it
should be called should I go to dance
school you know and I think no wait
should I get into cheese
shout out to the cheese makers you yeah
from from what I've seen in the three
YouTube documentaries you do not have an
easy job and you deserve higher wages
because dude that's honestly we gotta
have a cheesecast where we talk more
about this yeah at some point there's
there's one thing uh and I that I think
we've been circling and it's almost a
weirdly meta so like stay with me here
don't think you're gonna be visible in
this industry I think that's like a
really important thing in the sense that
like when you talk about grips and you
talk about like freelancing like you
have to be comfortable with the fact
that like you
can be an artist without like a million
people knowing who you are and
hold for the irony of us saying that on
a podcast right that's why I'm saying
this is meta it's like all of us have a
certain amount of like
people know who we are or know of the
thing that we do but like you don't know
who is the grip on Titanic you don't
know who the who the lighting designer
was on for the best picture this year
unless you're like way into that type of
thing that's all to say like
I I got lost in the sauce as a young
person like watching like influencer
Style videos about filmmaking on YouTube
thinking like I just have to be seen I
have to make things that are like
visible in that way and if you kind of
zoom out and you think about that
formula
it becomes very strange
um and
if accountants were making accountant
content that was as flashy as filmmakers
make filmmaker content by the way on
YouTube you would see how goofy it is
yeah you know and at the end of the day
this is an art and it's a huge industry
and know that like what you do in this
industry is important no matter who's
seeing it
and
it doesn't matter if you're talking to
one person or a million people like if
you do love what you do that's that's
the key yeah and I think that finding
that is like what you should be
searching for outside of Education
outside of a career yeah you know if
that's your goal to be seen and be like
an influencer who like does film or art
or whatever don't go to don't go to
school just start putting yourself on
camera yeah like yeah
yeah there are so many jobs and
thankless thankless you know uh hours
worked on film sets that you know just
no one ever bats an eye and like it
sucks because it's like oh yeah I love
that movie who's the director oh cool
yeah yeah he does great work it's like
he does great work for she does good
work yeah you're so right other people
just like slaving away to get this thing
done long hours especially that the
effects industry dude yeah man it's it's
crazy and there's there's certainly a
massive element also in the in the film
School side like everyone is out for
them in their own Department in their
own area and there's a lot of friendship
and camaraderie but at the end of the
day you're kind of responsible for
yourself so know yourself know what know
how into it you really are and you know
if you're thinking about leaving Film
School like like I was I didn't do it
lightly I I knew I'd have to explain to
my parents who would be devastated and
and I was scared because I didn't know
like am I really screwing this up well
all my classmates look down on me turns
out they like supported it and were like
dang that was so cool but I remember
when I was leaving
I had one thought and it like kind of
haunted me until I finally took the step
and it was if I'm not willing to bet on
me then why should anybody else
and that was one thing that I've always
kept in my head where I choose to invest
in myself because I know how much I want
this and I feel like as long as that's
the fuel that's pushing you you're gonna
make it yeah you know with film score
without with film school or without like
it is investing in yourself just don't
party the whole time just imagine do a
cost breakdown of like what's my tuition
per like hour in film school
that hurt me it hurts yeah and it's like
crap dude how much money money did I
just waste watching you know like so I
don't know like take it seriously if
you're gonna do this because it's super
expensive it is a lot of time away from
being on set there are benefits to it
um you know the people you meet the
networks you can make and the stuff if
you go to the right school that you can
actually use and have in your hand and
have access to yeah and all the other
you know liberal arts kind of knowledge
you can gain if you want
um but at the same time
you're going to be humbled either way I
think after you graduate and you need to
be ready to be humbled and
you know only then can you achieve
success I think I I really yeah I really
think so yeah I mean most of the stuff
that's available at film school it's
obviously it's more expensive than it's
ever been but it's also a really
exciting time to be an artist because
about I mean this is a guesstimate but
about 80 of what you have access to at
the film school you can find ways to get
outside of film school and so it's only
like the those Niche those Niche areas
like meeting people you can meet people
outside of film school I do it all the
time it's a very small community and
people will pass their name around I
promise
um so depending on your reasons for
going yeah I think it's it's something
that that more people should be open to
not that's all I'm going to say is it
might be right for you it might not be
and that's okay either one is totally
fine but I think that the conversation
of I need to go to school is nonsense
and you don't I think that's I think
that's per person sorry Mom and Dad yeah
show your parents this podcast if
they're if they're pushing you and
you're like I don't really know really
like hey hearing you know the
perspectives of four different artists
working in an industry yeah not the
industry and Industry in a parallel one
um maybe this would be useful I don't
know like I could have probably
benefited from hearing a podcast like
this when I was you know kind of hell
bent on on doing the whole school thing
yeah I don't know I had a very dear
friend in the industry who's my
directing partner who spoke that into me
saying like this is an 80 000 Medallion
like even where is uh that you wear
underneath your shirt no one's gonna see
it and he was the first one to push me
in this direction I wouldn't have done
it without him so hopefully this serves
us you know that encouragement to not do
it I don't think that's any of our
purpose here is just be open to what is
right for you because it is a it is a
wide spectrum of possibility which is
exciting but also daunting yeah
um but yeah trust yourself trust
yourself
because uh yeah as long as that's the
fuel he'll do great yeah man it's like
Just One Last anecdote
I was taking a directing class and like
you know directing a short film in film
school you know
the guy on campus you know hey um on set
walk on I'm the director you know
whatever I'm of course joking a little
bit but like that like same weekend like
I got a call from Jake and he's like hey
dude uh
I'm shooting like this little pilot and
like it's like down in La like do you
have a camera I can borrow like can you
just come like help out it's like okay
yeah the next day so I go down there and
it's just like I'm just like you know
helping set up lights and like they're
they're like using my camera like some
other guys shooting with my camera
because like I don't know I wasn't good
enough I guess
it's like
but it's that contact that you know
helped me get where I'm now you know
it's that humbling and that like yes I
will I'll do anything then I just want
to be on a set be gracious and eager and
available it paid off because you never
ever know who the person is that's going
to to help you in your next chapter
that's great advice man any other final
thoughts on this like
let us know your favorite cheeses
I think you know I'm really partial to
Pepper Jack
um now you know
I and this is something I haven't
touched on in this podcast but I took a
break in the middle of college mostly
because kovid kind of started I'm
exposing my youngness here but um and I
remember making that decision and also
the decision to go back so like as much
as I I might come off as a little
negative here I think it's really
important to finish the things that you
start yeah
um and I know that's like maybe a day
and this is what I mean like you start
you started thinking about not going and
you actually finished you you actually
committed to not going which is like
good like you didn't kind of waffle you
weren't that kid in film school was like
I hate it here everything sucks I don't
like it and then you just like stuck
around for four years being like a whiny
little mo like you know and I knew kids
like that who are like I'm better than
this and I'm like well you're here so
you know maybe be grateful and so that's
all to say no matter what you choose and
what you don't like listen to yourself
and it's important to like follow
through as an artist like that's
something that is hard to teach and
that's the most important thing that's
gonna carry you for your career because
if you can't finish a project
you will not make it in this industry
and Film School is a project right or
not going to film school as a project so
treat both that's good as seriously as
you would a film that you want to make
because you have to finish one thing to
move on to the next I've oh like this is
It's oldest time my mom used to tell me
this growing up finished one project
before you start another clean up after
yourself it's the same thing and so no
matter what you do just make sure you
really put a pin in whatever you do and
state claim to that decision
and then you'll be ready to take on the
next thing that's that's what I would
want to say yeah
Griffin any what's your closing thoughts
on School versus no school versus uh
Journey Jonah you nailed the title for
this video first of all I love that
you're thinking about that while we're
doing it you're like title thumbnail
ideas
I have been sitting here thinking about
what the thumbnails I love that
um I don't I don't think I really could
have could have said it better than
anyone else um just you know if if
college is what you need to do what you
want to do
a hundred percent do it
um make sure that to the best of your
ability you figure out what you want to
do instead of letting other people tell
you what you should do
yeah it's not it's not a mystical
machine that's gonna
convert you into something it's it's uh
it's a tool a very expensive tool so be
sure that you want that tool or need
that tool but uh yeah yeah I think it's
I'm glad we got to do this guys this is
this is something that's very very near
and dear to my heart with with my
experience so it's cool to hear your
guys experience too hopefully you guys
got something out of it uh thanks for
tuning in and uh we'll be back next time
you want to take us out Nick with a song
should we do that again is that about if
it's bad we'll cut it but if it's good
we'll keep we need to finish what we
started you're right remember the
harmonies yes okay all right three two
one
[Laughter]